in the lead-up to the release of Justice
League the central mystery for Savi fans
wasn't a super man going to be in this
thing but rather black suit yes or no
prior to November many would have hedged
towards yes considering tire merchandise
hyping up the suit and an Instagram post
from Henry Cavill that many took to be a
close-up of the black outfit but when
the movie hit theaters with a relatively
lean two hour runtime the black suit was
nowhere to be found
as such viewers expecting the black suit
were left feeling gaslighted wondering
if they had imagined the whole thing
was this really advertised maybe that
was a Henry Cavill fan account now a
thanks to cinematographer Fabian Wagner
it's finally been confirmed that the
suit that exists scenes were shots and
they didn't end up in the final edit
Wagner is fairly clear about this in an
interview with inverse responding to a
question regarding whether or not scenes
were shot involving the black suit there
were scene shots it's a cool-looking
costume sadly we didn't see that either
in the final cut
could the black suit casualty have been
the result of Warner Brothers wanted to
distance a movie from the aggressively
dark tone of Man of Steel and Batman vs
Superman it would make a lot of sense
considering what we know now about the
movie's troubled production Fabian
didn't explain what role the black suit
would have played in the film but the
comics have seen the Man of Steel sport
darker duds on several occasions the
most relevant occurrence happened in the
reign of the Superman story arc in which
Clark returns from the grave with a
black suit and long hair after the death
of Superman arc where he you know dies
fighting doomsday sound familiar
ultimately a Superman's black suit ended
up on the cutting room floor alongside
Willem Dafoe's appearance as volcko most
of Robin Wright spoken lines and cyborgs
backstory just another thing to wish for
in that director skirts thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love today
[Music]
you